thank you
[Music]
thank you everybody for tuning in to
another episode of just kidding news we
have our host Anthony
[Applause]
oh thank you Jason and let's give it up
for our guest Today Jason hey
so much for having me
why are you looking at before
hey you said that weird you said that
weird guy oh the way Jason's momentum
just rolls right off of a cliff and dies
is so crazy what do you mean die because
like you start and it's like let's go
dude people really love that they go one
of the most like funniest comments about
you is I love the way this guy tells a
story like he doesn't know what's gonna
happen
don't laugh don't laugh he doesn't even
know what's gonna happen I do know dude
you'll be saying ask me anything right
now halfway you'll be saying half the
word yeah at the end of the sentence
yeah and then change it right away to
something completely different yeah you
changed it completely different
it's like I never did what are we
talking about I have never done this why
are you bulldozing me yeah it'll be like
that okay speaking of questions change
anything by the way it's great thank you
so is that prompt for the day all the
fans want to know this about you okay
okay all right when you're in the mood
how do you get your partner in the mood
as well
um that's a good question I have a
question for you as well no that's the
question
Jason [ __ ] Riddler
this segment Works dude here's the
question he's like okay that's good
ladies first yeah dude come on bro hey
chivalry yeah yeah yeah I try to do
sugar all right yeah trying yeah
I did my best I appreciate it thank you
thank you well done
uh so I go
and she's what what is she doing give me
I don't you're in the mood and she's
washing dishes she's in the kitchen
she's doing some chores and she's not in
the mood at all but you are what do you
do okay I go like this I go close right
and I go thank you so much for helping
with everything
sweet
[Laughter]
hey Ben thank you so much for helping us
do these things
um something's gonna happen tonight
that's what you say look at me hey look
at me oh no look at me
okay
okay
look at me look at me okay
look at me
and that works no okay and then that's a
no and then I go away
and you try again later yeah I'll try to
get it later I would argue that you just
saying thank you and being aware that
she's doing something nice would be like
oh that's so sweet and then maybe she
goes into a different you know thought
process that's true and she goes maybe
he should just wash the dishes
it's not sexual at all yeah laughs
I go I could I could also take out the
trash you could do that you'd like uh me
to take out the trash
um and also
um I'll take it I'm gonna take a shower
is there anything are these things you
don't normally do
no I'm just I just want I heard it's up
close he's like maybe so tonight I'm
gonna take a shower and she gets off
whoa
something's different I want the jackpot
did you get promoted I really like the
line
tonight something's gonna happen
I really like the line
not not the way that I say it though not
the way I say it I go like this
something's gonna happen tonight
[Laughter]
zany she goes okay
somebody's going to get a hurt for me
some things are going to happen tonight
oh and then uh and I'm sure that works
for him what's your success rate though
um do you feel like it works out of two
five five out of 17. it's a nice
fraction maybe like half of the time
half of the time it works half of the
time it it doesn't work and that's okay
you just uh I think 50 is pretty
successful right that's pretty good she
ever come on to you yeah and then let's
say you're not in the mood what do you
how do you get rid of her I I go like
this I go oh my God I really want it but
I can't
no I don't I don't and then you laugh or
do you always want it do you always want
it it's a kid he's like I want it but I
can't
oh my God Jason's crazy this guy is
crazy instantly horny I love it I love
it has that ever happened where like
you're not in the mood and and you have
to decline sometimes I get tired because
uh gay bro
man look at you
You Gotta Throw It Down for the block
bro you can't just say no oh
put me down bro you know I said all
women know the standard it's always yes
in other news what about Anthony's orgy
cheers not to answer the question though
is the Colts one today
oh Hot Topic you're not in the mood and
you want to have an orgy how do you do
about it
[Laughter]
like it is
when you're out in the mood yeah man and
you want to well the reason why I was
having this conversation with my buddies
there at the gym and we're making jokes
how we have no systems we have no
systems to make this happen if we're in
the mood and my significant other is not
in the mood yeah it's not good it's over
it's done so okay what if she's in the
mood and you're not in the mood you
don't have any tricks up yourself you're
gonna get divorced over that there's got
to be some tricks up your sleeve yeah
see that's why I want to ask you guys
like what kind of tricks you got why are
you deflecting how about deflecting yeah
that's really good it's really good uh
you just ask questions to everybody else
usually what was your question
I forgot your question oh wow I was too
busy how do you get you're a lady on the
same plane as you when you're feeling
better usually okay look I'm probably
how is he always holding some form of
drumsticks but this time not drumsticks
I'm probably always like uh I'll say
this half hard yeah maybe it's like uh I
want to be on the starting five you know
what I mean so I'm always ready Off the
Bench your boy's ready to go wow okay
you're never not ready what does that
mean you're just you're just gonna have
hard you should always have a condom on
it
how did you put that on yeah oh it stays
up that means you're just usually not in
the top five that's my third
he's like I am the sixth man I am always
ready for the big leagues I'll say that
and the big league are you really ready
for the big leagues all the time yeah
always okay but how many times like how
many times like a week he's trying to
win the slam dunk contest I don't know I
don't think the frequency we're too busy
to be doing it like at least once a week
how about a month how many times a month
Ah that's a good question once a week I
actually uh probably like
I think the average becomes like
once a weekish but sometimes one week we
won't happen and then a couple times
another yeah or something like that just
the average it balances out crazy crazy
like does she like when you're all
sweaty from Jiu Jitsu no no oh no well I
don't think she has she doesn't like
dislike it I just don't want to be
because it's mainly someone else's sweat
huh yeah I just
threesome
you rolled
today didn't you did you train David you
know it's my favorite student oh God you
never come home with the key on and you
just untied the belt
yeah you ever done it with your Dion no
dude that's ridiculous why is it
disrespectful to your seafood or
something yeah dude is that how it goes
gonna know he's gonna feel in his heart
what if she puts the ghee on are you
like this is my kind of Realm
oh yeah that's weird
by like teaching her like moves and
you're like all right babe this is an
arm bar and then you go in also for the
kill anytime it happens it's always very
organic it's always just like what's
organic though it's like very it's very
guilty like you guys like you guys are
just suddenly getting like really kinky
it gets rough and suddenly you start
transitioning into a [ __ ] headlock no
dude we don't fight bro I don't I don't
do just but what's organic like you guys
are both washing the car and you guys
are having sex inside the car yeah we're
doing a [ __ ] Carl's Jr app
washing the car Daisy well he said
organic so I'm like okay what's the
organic situation it's like you know we
just started do you guys have looks like
she knows your look oh I start grabbing
her I go oh oh [ __ ]
I think he's deflecting that's not
deflected yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah but usually it's like
you will go like We'll always Reserve
time to go on like a date night or
something I've never seen Nick
uncomfortable yeah this is the first
time bro maximum uncomfortable I'm
[ __ ] chills and cucumbers the thing
is you never see it because he's
uncomfortable all the time
he's angry yeah I'm a little
uncomfortable most times I think yeah
but yeah it usually happens like we have
a date night that's a good one
set day per week no no it's always like
when we have time to like go on a date
night we'll do something like that and
then that's usually how it goes I think
is there a belt system for that at home
too yeah I'm still wiping frequency wise
she can go up a belt yeah well she she's
the sifu and she promotes me so like I
gotta wait for it this is a 10 minute 46
second Mark where we change the subject
for somebody else uh what about you Ryan
when you're in the mood
um what do you do just spark it up
I don't think there is a I think it's
like I think it is more of a physical
thing I don't think it's like if I
[ __ ] open my mouth and said anything
I would instantly turn anyone off
there's no good dialogue for me you know
it's funny you try it every time don't
you like this idiot no I think I think
I've learned early on that my strength
in attractiveness does not lie in
anything verbal same you gotta read the
the book of 51 liners
thing it didn't work
but what if you tried doing this like
yeah yeah does that mean you just go to
your keyboard and you start doing stuff
and stuff no I've never yeah you
serenade I've never used that as a thing
that doesn't work no it's not like
purposely
it does work and that's why I don't I
don't like to do that why because so you
have so many talents that you could put
them aside great he wants to handicap it
because I believe that there was one
time I really believe that there's one
time to like this girl who who I didn't
think wanted to date me and then I did
that and I regretted it because then she
wanted to date me because of that and
kind of overlooked other things that
maybe she wouldn't have liked and then
we got to a point where we started
arguing about [ __ ] I'm like what the
[ __ ] did you do oh that's right I
shouldn't have [ __ ] played that Spice
Girl song
and it was a Spice Girl song
you become one no it was a it was a
different one but um I remember doing
that because like she I was trying to
get her and I was like [ __ ] like she's
so independent couldn't get her to date
me it was like ages ago and then I was
like what's your [ __ ] favorite song
then and she goes oh it's this song
Whatever
hold on a second
if you want to be meet me in the lobby
by the grand piano in five
minutes and then uh yeah that was it but
it's it's un it's not a bad pretense
okay first of all if it was me and you
said what's your favorite song and then
you said meet me in five minutes and you
learned it right I would [ __ ] suck
your dick too I'm soaked right now
that's like eventually it's like that
[ __ ] that's not gonna be enough to
hold the relationship up the other shirt
you just gotta play other songs
did you just play some more so yeah
because of that I've never what's your
next favorite I never I never do that
now what's your dad's favorite song I
try to I try to present all of my most
like kind of shitty traits and if they
survive liking me at that point then I'm
like okay we will make it yeah you know
what I mean but it's like that's why I
think like with who I am today with
smack it helps because we're friends for
such a long time that she's seen me act
like a [ __ ] idiot completely you know
I'm just curious what's one of your
shitty traits that you think
I um like what like is this like what
are my weaknesses kind of job interview
type thing
I care too much I
are lacking or area you wished you could
improve that's what the discussions
and then after how do you turn around
[Laughter]
the original
that vendogo of conversation is very
interesting and that's organic I'll tell
you I'll tell you a real one I think
um I get obsessively good at certain
things and I never apply them
I think that's the thing that in the
long run you could not appreciate oh but
you don't why why don't you know I don't
know I just don't I just really enjoy
getting good at stuff and then like like
I'll just never make anything out of it
I'll just be really good at a certain
thing make a career or commercialize it
or something and then like I'll get tons
of tons of people in different
Industries always go dude you could be
making money doing that and it's just
not interesting to me what's the last
thing you got really good at that you
didn't apply I feel like you're right I
know I got really good at uh at
um at hacking and coding old school
Nintendo games
right I got obsessively good at that to
a degree that I have no business in but
then like I didn't I just did it to make
a funny uh funny game for my friends in
this game yeah oh yeah oh yeah we were
in the zoo
we weren't in this game Hot Boys huh I
didn't know you then but I will make you
a whole game now no no nothing about
toothpaste that's like Mark Wahlberg and
the other guys you know he like learned
ballerina to make fun of the other
people
the quick is down the street and that I
think is a flaw that like if you were
dating like if you're dating me for a
long time I think you'll catch out of
that and go like oh this guy doesn't
really apply himself fully I think
that's a fair assessment but it's great
in that moment I'm like well we get to
experience this for
x amount of time until the next thing
yeah but you don't have to apply
everything you like a thing and then
you're good at it and you do another
thing you're good at it you still know
uh another thing yeah
that's a very true in perspective I
don't think you have to do it but I also
would agree with a partner that was
disappointed that I don't well what are
you gonna play You're Gonna apply
everything that you learn it's like
that's not even yeah exactly [ __ ]
fisherman one week being good at the
thing like to myself yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying what are you gonna apply
yourself all the time
no I like to think that you're not the
school counselor yeah dude you're good
you're good yeah no that's actually a
good point I'm passionate about like
it's not your career you're just doing
like the game thing you're like I'm not
gonna be a [ __ ] I just like stuff
yeah then like that's the thing is like
I can understand it if if I'm with
somebody and they see me spending so
much time yeah getting good at things
that only I will ever see it's a little
weird for them I think I think it's more
about saying this to the people out
there that have zero Talent and can't
get good at anything and then you think
about that person who's just kind of
gifted at everything and you're like man
they don't even use their skills and you
get all insecure
hey dude hey I have something to ask you
no no what it's a 16 minute Mark I saw
that time too yep you know what that
[ __ ] means we're gonna Circle back to
clean me because all I have to do with
16. we want to hear how you do it how
the master I'm no master I'm only a
masturbator in this conversation have
you ever have you ever encountered that
is that foreign to you like a girl not
being in the mood with you you're a
[ __ ] tool
is it like like how an African tribe
that's never seen civilization sees a
helicopter
is it similar I thought those are South
American anyways
um what's your what's your what do you
do
to
you guys are all idiots I know it's hard
to imagine but I came up with this
prompt because I want to hear what you
do and I can steal it I also learned
even though I choose not to learn
because I know the result but I just
think it's funny just like Ryan nothing
I will ever say works the second I say
it also is turns down but for some
reason that doesn't mean I won't from
time to time just uh pause what are
these phrases that you guys are saying
that you think would work mostly from
the no we know
[Music]
what a Time
oh that's a good one she's like you just
got home what are you talking about yeah
it's like that's not what the Bible says
it's in the new New Testament the new
new the new new
no that's that's a stupid joke the fact
that you say the words though no no no
no words never worked okay what's the
move
you got a guy right there you could demo
on just okay so for me so for me I've
come to learn in the depth of my
relationship now that I have to do
[Laughter]
is now I feel like I have to do like
eight things to even set myself up to
maybe there's a chance what were they
think okay so first off when you say
things like when you say things like you
go to your girl and she's like watching
this it's like all the dishes need to be
done the laundry needs to be done the
vacuum is just all the chores everything
already needs to be handled so that she
has nothing to complain about and then
if she's okay in the mood after that I
need to have showered and I need to be
clean and ready to go and then even that
I shouldn't say anything I need to make
sure that she might be in the mood which
means that I can't be like hey I want
something I have to only pretend like I
want to give it I don't even want it I
just want to give I'm just like so you
just put [ __ ] Lube all over your
mouth
I'm ready
do you have him walking around all day
just going
to be that's on you
on you I just want to give it
oh wait hold on a second don't sit here
okay well what does ready to give me you
know ready to give me you ever saw
somebody like that in public
that's him eight
[Laughter]
that's why that visual still stuck in my
head no like uh is anybody related you
guys leave me on either oh you're good
you're already ready to give instead of
like asking to take like so for example
um I think a younger really uh arrogant
cocky version of myself if I was trying
to get into maybe like you're cuddling
on the bed you start like making out
where the [ __ ] and then like a very
naive and stupid ignorant younger
version of you might have like taken you
know a partner's hand and like put it on
me to begin and like you know what I
mean but realizing instead it's more
like at their level you know and also
with no no expectation but maybe you go
there and then if she's in the mood you
get her in the mood not about you being
in the middle but it's like you get her
in the mood if she's in the mood you
might get some if you get her in the
mood you don't get some you don't get
some you know what I mean it's just it's
just at that point of the relationship
but of course because it's also in that
part of the relationship my dumb ass
sometimes when I don't want to do all
the work and do all the chores sometimes
like hey can I just get a [ __ ] like
that yeah
done washing the dishes and she's like
sure honey be right there would you be
like whoa I'll probably bust a nut
already
[Music]
sure honey I'll be right there yeah it
would never work but that's I think
that's why you try it from time to time
it's like it's my birthday
in that moment with her just saying that
that's an easy tip for women to like get
out of it sure honey I'll be right there
you bust a nut you're like oh I guess
you're done you got a sense that they
are at that Peak they're believing it uh
but it's Gotta Be believable if it
sounds like an excuse the nut's not
coming out oh yeah what needs this to be
true it's got to be yeah yeah that's
cool man I feel like the love language
helped too that's what it is because if
their love language is like you know
active service or whatever or like
Spanish like feeling or what's Spanish
or another guy in Spanish what's my
what's your love language
um
that's actually a very good too how
about after Hector you know so yeah once
you're done with Hector yeah hit your
boy up what is your love language would
you say dude it's physical quality time
oh
hi
I was like oh guys shut up Nick uh
quality time all guys I think most of
them mine's quality time yeah all right
so you're saying you spend like six
hours of quality time or something and
then you're like horny out of somewhere
like just out of nowhere you're just
horny love language means
because it's isn't there like two main
ones there's like one and then sub two
I think the love language means it's
like your currency of affection yeah I
know but like there's a top one there's
like everybody has like a primary and a
secondary you just I think you rank it
like one two five so what's like your
top two so first one quality time
quality time and the second one is I
think acts of service me too my I think
physical touch and quality time wow I
wouldn't have thought really you're so
ticklish
I just like cuddling wait quality time
and physical touch yeah I just like
doing this bro we could totally be in a
relationship yeah we're gonna because
it's so easy to do like physical touch
and words of affirmation but active
service is so hard that's what yeah yeah
that's true because you could do the
wrong thing yeah you could do the wrong
thing and they might not like it or you
you know do too much it's time time
consuming but then if it's physical
touch I just touch you and say I love
you yeah yeah dude that's great this is
I think hers is no I think but hers is
quality time number one and the number
two is probably
about the same guy
thank you
[Music]